the 2001 comedy Zoolander features an
array of Hollywood celebs in its cast
besides course stars like Ben Stiller
Owen Wilson and Will Ferrell the movie
boasts appearances by actors like Judah
Friedlander Alexander Skarsgard and Andy
Dick among many other famous faces but
chances are you may have missed one
major celebrity who was hiding in plain
sight after Stiller's model character
Derek Zoolander is captured by villain
mugatu's evil team henchmen Katinka
played by real-life supermodel Milla
Jovovich signals to a DJ to start the
brainwashing process the performer
donning dreadlocks a stub of beard on
his chin and a nasty looking facial scar
puts down a record and starts playing a
remix of relaxed by the popular 80s band
Frankie Goes to Hollywood the
gold-toothed body also memorably fights
Wilson's Hansel in a breakdancing battle
because why not but just who was the man
portraying the devious disc jockey none
other than Justin Theroux yep the guy
who starred in the HBO drama the
leftovers played the character evil DJ
and apparently those breakdancing moves
were all his Theroux told host Conan
O'Brien in September 2014 learn when I
was around I don't know twelve or
thirteen somewhere in there how to
breakdance and I had a little crew that
we used to roll around wash debris
Stiller apparently decided to make use
of Thoreau's skills for Zoolander after
seeing him breakdance at his wedding to
actress Christine Taylor throat later
reprised the character of evil DJ for
the comedies 2016 sequel Zoolander 2 the
screenplay for which he also helped
write with Stiller nicholas stoller and
john hamburg
relax he also dressed as evil DJ on the
red carpet for the premiere of the
second film posing for cameras in a
white New York Yankee city and gold
sneakers as reported by Hello magazine
how's the family reunion going great I'd
like to check him out for a few hours if
that's okay regarding working on
Zoolander 2 with Stiller Thoreau told
Business Insider in 2016 I think we were
all like let's not try to beat the first
one let's not think about it like that
let's think about where the characters
would be historically ten years later
and see if there's a funny idea of them
being aged out he continued we basically
decided to run right at the fact that
yeah they are older instead of trying to
pickup the movie one day after or one
week later we thought it would be funny
if they were washed up and had to come
back into the industry his role in
Zoolander and Zoolander to aside Thoreau
has made a name for himself on the small
and big screens with projects like
maniac the girl on the train and on the
basis of sex not only an actor he's also
a writer lending his talents to the 2008
comedy Tropic Thunder and the 2010
Marvel movie Iron Man 2 despite his long
list of film and TV gigs fans of
celebrity news may know him best for his
relationship with movie star and Friends
alum Jennifer Aniston as noted by
Cosmopolitan magazine Thoreau and
Aniston were first thought to have
gotten together in May 2011 and before
long the two reportedly moved in
together by August 2012 Thoreau had
proposed to his ladylove and the
celebrity couple tied the knot in August
2015
unfortunately thorough and Aniston
wouldn't remain together On February
15th 2018 they announced that they had
separated saying in a joint statement
reported by Us Weekly we our two best
friends who have decided to part ways as
a couple but look forward to continuing
our cherished friendship but don't feel
too bad fourth row he appears to be
doing well following the heartbreaking
breakup and he has at least one major
acting gig on the horizon in July 2018
Collider announced that the row would be
voicing the character of [ __ ] in
Disney's remake of lady in the [ __ ] as
for lady she'll reportedly be voiced by
thor ragnarok Tessa Thompson who would
have guessed that Evil DJ would wind up
working for the House a mess check out
one of our newest videos right here
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you